en journée de halage pour ces mariniers
du loiret à l'occasion de son centième
anniversaire
ils sont autorisés à naviguer sur cette
portion du canal d'orléans nous une
pratique interdite depuis 1954
il n'y a pas de moteur dont il n'y a pas
de bruit de moteur c'est que la force
des hommes et qui sont sur le bord et
les bourdes heures au maintenir en ligne
voilà c'est que du plaisir
c'est pas toujours facile mais ça serait
simple on s'ennuierait partie de
saint-jean-de-braye en direction
d'orléans
ces bateaux parcours près de 4 km à la
seule force des bras des signaleurs une
tâche autrefois confié aux femmes et aux
enfants
on est toutes les équipes en tire
ensemble on essaye en tout cas et puis
on rigole bien de temps en temps le plus
compliqué c'est peut-être quand le canal
s'élargit comme à l'arrivée par exemple
là on voit que l'accord n'est plus dans
laxe du bateau donc on va il faut
ralentir quoi si on veut bien de
personnes à l'eau cette balade n'est pas
dénué de sens pour ses organisateurs
ils veulent interpeller les institutions
sur le manque d'entretien du canal nous
dans notre petite tête de mariniers
assez la navigation qui nous intéresse
donc on a des plans d'eau des ouvrages
magnifique donc l'intérêt c'est de le
faire fonctionner et à d'autant plus qu'
il est dit qu'il y à des touristes qui
vont arriver avec l'aménagement de la sq
en libérer jusqu'ici la variante 2
la loire à vélo donc il ya un certain
nombre de touristes qui va passer donc
il faut leur faire voir un spectacle
digne de ce nom
la douzaine d'embarcations est arrivé à
bon port à la capitainerie d'orléans ce
dimanche en fin d'après midi